joe biden's tyrannical vaccine mandate
for private sector employers bites the
dust but the left wing of the court
reminds americans that we were one
presidency away from complete
administrative tyranny in this country
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the bench bureau show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first you should know that
when you spend money with many of your
corporate friends they are spending that
money on a bunch of stuff that you don't
particularly like you vote every single
month with the money you spend and the
companies you spend it with so if you
are still a customer of verizon or att
or t-mobile you are choosing to support
the candidates and issues that they
donate to so that means your funding
indirectly biden pelosi schumer the
leftist agenda they're pushing but here
is a solution pure talk see pure talk as
i've said uses the exact same towers as
the big guys same 5g network as one of
those companies but with the peace of
mind that you are supporting a
veteran-run business a business whose
employees are right here in the united
states so yes this is one monthly bill
you can be proud to pay and here's the
thing you're gonna be saving a lot of
money when you use pure talk as opposed
to one of the big guys in fact your bill
is probably gonna be about half of what
your current cell phone bill is because
the average family saves over eight
hundred dollars a year so do this go to
puretalk.com find the plan that's right
for you find the phone that's right for
you or just bring your own then because
they love my listeners enter promo code
ben shapiro and you will save 50 off
your very first month that is
puretalk.com
promo code ben shapiro to get started
alrighty so today is a massive day for
us here at the daily wire we are so
proud that we at daily wire fought this
thing from the very start we fought it
from day one we said we were not going
to comply and we didn't and then we
spent hundreds of thousands of dollars
to fight this thing in court we were the
first company in america to file a
federal lawsuit against the biden
administration literally within minutes
of them promulgating the regulation
legally we went to court in the sixth
circuit court of appeals we could not
have done that without those of you who
are members and who have helped make
this happen for us please if you're not
a member consider joining up today and
helping us fight because that's what we
do here at daily wire head on over to
dailywire.com
subscribe for today only promo code
winning it gets you 40 off an entire
year's membership so you can support us
all year long we have amazing content
but you're really helping the cause more
than anything else dailywire.com
subscribe use promo code winning because
we're going to keep on winning to get 40
off that annual membership the supreme
court ruled 6-3 yesterday that joe
biden's vaccine mandate via osha was
wildly unconstitutional because as it
turns out it is wildly unconstitutional
it is a violation of the separation of
powers
it is a violation of the enabling
act of the of the
original body itself osha the
occupational safety and health safety
and health administration
and it was being used as a cudgel by the
executive branch of the government to
simply end around the constitutional
process of working through a legislature
see here in the united states there's
this thing called the constitution the
constitution mandates that if you're
going to effectuate a major policy you
need to go through this thing called the
legislature the legislature is in its
turn comprised of two separate bodies
the house of representatives which is a
portion according to population and the
senate of the united states in which
each state gets two senators i know this
is really basic stuff but apparently
people on the left need to hear this the
new republic today
the new republic
not even kidding you they tweeted out
today the new republic which is supposed
to be a sophisticated liberal magazine
quote the real supreme court ruling
appears to be this the biden
administration can only try new
solutions to new problems if it runs
them through a gerrymandered house and a
filibuster friendly senate first
oh you mean you can only do things that
you don't have the authority to do if
you are given that authority by the
congress of the united states who could
have suspected such a thing except for
everyone who has ever read the
constitution of the united states it's
just unbelievable okay so the supreme
court ruled 6-3 in favor of getting rid
of joe biden's vacs mandate and the
language was pretty strong here we're
going to go through it
and as we do i want you to remember that
there were three justices on the other
side breyer kagan sotomayor and those
three justices on the other side rule
that the occupational safety and health
administration
with no actual statutory authority
could force 100 million americans to
vaccinate because they had jobs
that is what the left of the court said
that an obscure agency that generally
you have no interface with
that obscure agency granted power by an
act in the 70s
suddenly had the authority to decide
whether you had to vaccinate
whether or not you had natural immunity
or religious objection or some sort of
existing condition that prevented you
from getting the vaccine safely that you
had to vaccinate or lose your job three
justices on the supreme court said that
that was totally fine
and uh if if hillary clinton had been
elected in 2016 that would have been
five or six justices on the supreme
court of the united states because
remember president trump got three picks
all three voted the right way in this
particular case
all right so here's what the court ruled
yesterday the secretary of labor acting
through the occupational safety and
health administration recently enacted a
vaccine mandate for much of the nation's
workforce
the mandate which employers must enforce
applies to roughly 84 million workers
covering virtually all employers with at
least 100 employees it requires that
government workers receive a covet 19
vaccine it preempts contrary state laws
the only exception is for workers who
obtain a medical test each week at their
own expense and on their own time and
also wear a mask each workday osha has
never before imposed such a mandate nor
has congress indeed although congress
has enacted significant legislation
addressing the kova 19 pandemic it has
declined to enact any measure similar to
what osha has promulgated here
many states businesses and nonprofit
organizations challenged osha's rule in
courts of appeals across the country the
fifth circuit initially entered a stay
but when the cases were consolidated
before the sixth circuit that court
lifted the stay and allowed osha's rule
to take effect
applicants now seek emergency relief
from this court arguing osha's mandate
exceeds its statutory authority and is
otherwise unlawful agreeing that
applicants are likely to prevail we
grant their applications and stay the
rule remember there's a preliminary
injunction because the rule didn't even
go into a fact
so the supreme court then goes through
the history of the occupational safety
and health act which was created in 1970
the act created osha the occupational
safety and health administration which
is part of the department of labor and
under the supervision of its secretary
as its name suggests osha is tasked with
ensuring occupational safety that is
safe and helpful working conditions
it does so by enforcing occupational
safety and health standards promulgated
by the secretary
such standards must be reasonably
necessary or appropriate to provide safe
or healthful employment
it must also be developed using a
rigorous process that includes notice
comment and an opportunity for a public
hearing however there's an exception
you're allowed to also promulgate
emergency temporary standards
such standards may take immediate effect
upon publication in the federal register
this is only permissible in extremely
narrow circumstances
it's only been used nine times before
this emergency authority six of those
times it was challenged in court only
one of those was upheld in full
okay so the supreme court goes through
the process by which the biden
administration created this osha rule
and um and the supreme court then points
out
that applicants are likely to succeed on
the merits of their claim that the
secretary lacked authority to impose the
mandate administrative agencies are are
creatures of statute they accordingly
possess only the authority congress has
provided right congress says that osha
can do x osha cannot do x y and z osha
can only do x and if ocean proclaims
that z is part of x osha has exceeded
its mandate under its enabling act
the secretary has ordered 84 million
americans to either obtain a covet-19
vaccine or undergo weekly medical
testing at their own expense
this is no everyday exercise of federal
power it is instead a significant
encroachment into the lives and health
of a vast number of employees
this is the supreme court we expect
congress to speak clearly when
authorizing an agency to exercise powers
of vast economic and political
significance there can be little doubt
that osha's mandate qualifies as an
exercise of such authority the question
then is whether the act plainly
authorizes the secretary's mandate it
does not the act empowers the secretary
to set workplace safety standards not
broad public health measures
no provision of the act addresses public
health more generally which falls
outside of osha's sphere of expertise so
in other words
it is true that covert 19 is a threat
inside the workplace it is also a threat
outside the workplace and everywhere
else that human beings congregate
and as the supreme court is about to say
just because you have a job doesn't mean
that the court can now do that osha can
now do whatever it wants to you so for
example
osha could not promulgate a rule saying
that obesity is a serious problem at the
workplace because there are people at
the workplace and obesity is a problem
therefore it is a serious workplace
problem therefore you're not allowed to
eat fatty foods at your workplace via
osha via osha regulation there's nothing
that would allow that sort of thing
the descent protests were imposing a
limit found no place in the governing
statute not so says the supreme court it
is the text of the agency's organic act
that repeatedly makes clear that osha is
charged with regulating occupational
hazards and the safety and health of
employees
the solicitor general does not dispute
that osha is limited to regulating
work-related dangers she instead argues
the risk of contracting covet 19
qualifies as such a danger we cannot
agree although covet 19 is a risk that
occurs in many workplaces it is not an
occupational hazard in most covenant 19
can and does spread at home in schools
during sporting events everywhere else
people gather that kind of universal
risk is no different from the day-to-day
dangers that all face from crime air
pollution or any number of communicable
diseases
permitting osha to regulate the hazards
of daily life simply because most
americans have jobs and face those same
risks while on the clock would
significantly expand osha's regulatory
authority without clear congressional
authorization
the dissent says the supreme court
contends that osha's mandate is
comparable to a fire or sanitation
regulation imposed by the agency but a
vaccine mandate is strikingly unlike the
workplace regulations that osha has
typically imposed a vaccination after
all cannot be undone at the end of the
workday
contrary to the descent's contention
imposing a vaccine mandate on 84 million
americans in response to a worldwide
pandemic is simply not part of what the
agency was built for that is not to say
osha lacks authority to regulate
occupation-specific risks related to
covet-19 where the virus poses a special
danger because of the particular
features of an employee's job or
workplace targeted regulations are
plainly permissible we don't doubt for
example that osha could regulate
researchers who work with kova 19.
osha could regulate risks associated
with working in particularly crowded or
cramped environments but the danger
present in such workplaces differs in
both degree and kind from the everyday
risk of contracting covenanting that all
face
then they point out
that the senate of the united states
actually voted against greenlighting
exactly this procedure there was a
procedural vote that was brought up
before the senate and the senate
symbolically said we don't like this
regulation which is a pretty good
indicator congress does not mean to
grant this sort of authority to osha
the supreme court says the equities do
not justify withholding interim relief
we're told by the states and the
employers that osha's mandate will force
them to incur billions of dollars in
unrecoverable compliance costs and will
cause hundreds of thousands of employees
to leave their jobs
for its part the federal government says
the mandate will save over 6 500 lives
and prevent hundreds of thousands of
hospitalization
the supreme court says it is not our
role to waste such trade-offs in our
system of government that is the
responsibility of those chosen by the
people through the democratic process
although congress has indisputably given
osha the power to regulate occupational
dangers it has not given that agency the
power to regulate public health more
broadly
requiring the vaccination of 84 million
americans simply because they have jobs
certainly falls in the latter category
okay so that is the majority supreme
court opinion 6-3 then
there is also the concurrence when the
concurrence goes further this from
gorsuch thomas and alito we'll get to
that in just one second because it makes
some pretty important points about the
legislative branch and why we still need
a legislative branch in the united
states
this really was a clash of massive ideas
as to the future of the country if this
had gone the other way it would
essentially spell the end truly of
anything remotely like the
constitutional structure in the united
states
essentially we would be living under
full administrative fiat at the behest
of the wild left
greenlit by justices on the supreme
court if this is going the other way
we'll get to that in just one moment
first
check take a look around your house it
feels like you know pretty good right i
mean you've cleaned up it looks pretty
good but it feels like slightly dingy
you're having a tough time realizing
what is it about it it's the window
coverings right look at them right now
yep i know you're looking they're dingy
you need to go over to blinds.com right
now in 2022 blinds.com is all about
celebrating you get up to 40 off
sitewide right now custom window
treatments are a minor home improvement
with a major impact blinds.com makes it
easy and affordable upgrade one room or
tackle your whole house shop huge
discounts on premium blinds shades
shutters and more all backed by their
100 satisfaction guarantee
with blinds.com there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees that's
why they are the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings with
over forty thousand 000 five-star
reviews whether you do it yourself or
let them handle the installation
blinds.com's free professional design
consultants are always available to help
blinds.com wants to thank their
customers by celebrating you with big
savings in 2022 shopblinds.com right now
save up to 40 off site wide go to
blinds.com get up to 40 off site wide
going on right now that's blinds.com for
up to 40 off rules and restrictions may
apply okay so
on to the concurrence in this case this
is gorsuch thomas and alito they say the
central question we face today is who
decides no one doubts that the covet-19
pandemic has posed challenges for every
american or that our state local and
national governments all have roles to
play in combating the disease the only
question is whether an administrative
agency in washington one charged with
overseeing workplace safety may mandate
the vaccination or regular testing of 84
million people or whether as 27 states
before us submit that work belongs to
state and local governments across the
country and the people's elected
representatives in congress this court
is not a public health authority but it
is charged with resolving disputes about
which authorities possess the power to
make the laws that govern us under the
constitution and the laws of the land
and essentially what they say is state
and local governments have extraordinary
plenary authority when it comes to
regulation of health this is not true of
the federal government the federal
government's powers are not general but
limited and divided
say the three
concurring justices not only must the
federal government properly invoke a
constitutionally enumerated source of
authority to regulate in this area or
any other it must also act consistently
with the constitution's separation of
powers
and when it comes to that obligation
this court has established at least one
firm rule we expect congress to speak
clearly if it wishes to assign to an
executive agency decisions of vast
economic and political significance
we sometimes call this the major
questions doctrine osha's mandate fails
that doctrine's test the agency claims
the power to force 84 million americans
to receive a vaccine or undergo regular
testing by any measure that is a claim
of power to resolve a question of vast
national significance yet congress has
nowhere clearly assigned so much power
to osha approximately two years have
passed since the pandemic began vaccines
have been available for more than a year
over that span congress has adopted
several major pieces of legislation
aimed at combating kovit19 it seems too
that the agency pursued its regulatory
initiative only as a legislative
workaround
okay what's hilarious about that
particular note right there which is
that osha created this because they
couldn't get it done in the legislature
is that ron claine literally tweeted
that joe biden's chief of staff tweeted
that and then that tweet was cited as
evidenced by the concurrence in this
case saying you guys can't do that it
violates the constitutional structure so
well done biden administration i mean
just admitted what you were doing and
the court caught you
what is osha's reply it directs us to 29
usc us code section 655 c1 in that
statutory subsection says the
concurrence congress authorized osha to
issue emergency regulations upon
determining that employees are exposed
to grave danger from exposure to
substances or agents determined to be
toxic or physically harmful and that
such emergency standards are necessary
to protect employees from such danger
according to the agency this provision
supplies with almost unlimited
discretion to mandate new nationwide
rules in response to the pandemic so
long as those rules are reasonably
related to workplace safety
the court rightly applies the major
questions doctrine and concludes that
this loan statutory subsection is not
clearly authorized osha's mandate
that section was not adopted in response
to the pandemic but 50 years ago at the
time of osha's creation since then osha
has relied on it to issue only
comparatively modest rules addressing
dangers uniquely prevalent inside the
workplace like asbestos and rare
chemicals
as the agency itself explained to the
federal court less than two years ago
the statute does not authorize osha to
issue sweeping health standards that
affect workers lives outside the
workplace but that is exactly what they
are trying to do right now
the concurrence continues they say why
does the major questions doctrine matter
it ensures the national government's
power to make the laws that govern us
remains where article 1 of the
constitution says it belongs with the
people's elected representatives if
administrative agencies seek to regulate
the daily lives and liberties of
millions of americans the doctrine says
they must at least be able to trace that
power to a clear grant of authority from
congress
and then the court continues say in this
respect the major questions doctrine is
closely related to what is sometimes
called the non-delegation doctrine
indeed for decades courts have cited the
non-delegation doctrine as a reason to
apply the major questions doctrine
essentially the non-delegation doctrine
says the legislative branch of the
government cannot just say
cannot pass a law saying to the
executive branch do whatever you want
right that is a delegation of powers
that cannot delegate
and so the way you can tell if the
non-delegation doctrine has been
violated is if there are major questions
that have been left wildly open to the
interpretation of executive branch
agencies say the concurrences the
non-delegation doctrine ensures
democratic accountability by by
preventing congress from intentionally
delegating its legislative powers to
unelected officials
sometimes lawmakers may be tempted to
delegate power to agencies to reduce the
degree to which they will be held
accountable
if congress could hand off all
legislative powers to unelected agency
officials it would dash the whole scheme
of our constitution
the major questions doctrine serves a
similar function by guarding against
unintentional oblique or otherwise
unlikely delegations of the legislative
power sometimes there's ambiguity and
agencies take advantage for example
whichever the doctrine the point is the
same both serve to prevent government by
bureaucracy supplanting government by
the people
and both hold their lessons for today's
case is the concurrence
on the one hand osha claims the power to
issue a nationwide mandate on a major
question but can't trace its authority
to do so to any clear congressional
mandate on the other hand if the
statutory subsection the agency cites
really did endow osha with that power
that law would likely constitute an
unconstitutional delegation of
legislative authority
under osha's reading the law would
afford it almost unlimited discretion
and this is the key point and this is
the key point that the concurrence is
making
the legislature still exists and because
the legislature still exists and ought
to exist osha does not have this
authority if congress wants to pass a
law like this it actually has to make
the case that it wants that it's going
to pass the law like this
okay so in a second we will get to the
descent because to me the descents in
this case are spine chilling they really
are they should chill your blood
at first gensake came out yesterday
posted the decision from the white house
she says don't worry joe biden is still
going to encourage businesses to
implement the vax mandate here's the
thing if a business chooses to implement
that vax mandate that is now on the
business that business no longer gets to
blame joe biden or the federal
government
this also gives the lie to a lot of a
lot of businesses that were saying we're
going to preemptively do this under the
assumption that it was going to be green
lit by the supreme
court now you didn't have to you guys
didn't have to you could have stood up
for your employees
here's jen saki saying they're going to
encourage businesses to continue this
anyway
the sen the the supreme court's decision
on the osha mandate essentially means
that in the pandemic it is up to
individual employers to determine
whether their workplaces will be safe
for employees and whether their
businesses will be safe for consumers so
president biden you'll see this in his
statement
will be calling on and will continue to
call on businesses to immediately join
these those who have already stepped up
including one-third of fortune 100
companies uh to institute vaccination
requirements to protect their workers
customers and communities okay so they
can encourage as much as they want but
that's not what they were attempting to
do they were attempting to destroy
businesses that refused to comply
they were literally threatening
businesses with 14 000 fines for every
unintentional violation and 140 000
fines for every intentional violation
they would have bankrupted our company
inside of a weak that was their goal
that was their explicit goal here and it
wasn't to shut down the virus because
they can't do that not with omicron it
was to control that's all they care
about and it comes from a deep-seated
view of the world that is perverse and
un-american i'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about saving
some money on your gas bill so you're
spending too much money on gas thanks to
supply chain issues and thanks to joe
biden's inflationary policies your gas
bills are just out of control this is
why you should go get get upside my
listeners are making up to 25 cents for
every gallon of gas every time they fill
up just download that free get upside
app in the app store or google play
right now use promo code shapiro get a
bonus 25 cents per gallon on your first
fill up that's up to 50 cents cash back
don't pay full price at the pump anymore
get cash back using get upside just
download the app for free use promo code
shapiro to get up to 50 cents per gallon
cash back on your first tank some people
who drive a lot are making as much as
two to three hundred bucks a month in
cash back there is no catch the cash
back gets added directly to your account
you can cash out anytime to your bank
account paypal or any gift card for
amazon and other brands just download
that free get upside app use promo code
shapiro get up to 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your very first tank of gas
that is promo code shapiro get that free
get upside app today honestly look what
is the downside there is none which is
why it's called get upside go check it
out right now get that get upside app
and use promo code shapiro get 50 cents
per gallon cashback on that first tank
of gas and then 25 cents per gallon on
every tank of gas after that alrighty so
the mentality of the descent is really
worth noting here okay because we were
this close in 2016 this close to
complete administrative tyranny in this
country
the descent in this case does not
attempt to make a constitutional
argument they don't attempt to look at
the major questions doctrine or
non-delegation doctrine they simply say
that if there is a vaguely worded
statute and is tossed over to
administrative agencies those
administrative agencies should be able
to control every aspect of your life
without any interference from the courts
you should not be able to sue
because those people are best placed to
actually determine the course of your
they're the experts
if we could just toss all governance in
the united states to the experts
at the administrative agencies and then
the supreme court could say listen we're
not experts it's up to those experts
well what you would have is
administrative tyranny
and if not for the justices appointed by
president trump
that would be the way the government is
done from here on out in the united
states
in some areas it's already pretty close
to that
but it would have been full-scale
administrative tyranny top down you
admit you elect your administrative
tyrant once every four years
a left-wing court strikes down the
excesses of right-wing presidents
and green lights all of the excesses of
left-wing presidents and the legislature
would become what it has been for quite
a while a vestigial organ of american
government
this is what the left wants because all
you have to do is cite an emergency and
the left is is fond of they love
emergencies emergencies happen all the
time climate change is an emergency
racism is an emergency poverty is an
emergency cover 19 is an emergency
now i'm not saying kova 19 wasn't an
emergency at the beginning it was but um
it's not emergency now it is not
but they are going to maintain forever
that emergencies are the way things are
done
that's what's at stake in this country
two very different views of what
government is supposed to do
it was amazing so yesterday i tweeted
out at the daily wire and again we are
very proud of standing up on behalf of
our employees
and um and i can tell you that they are
very happy to be working here today they
signed up for a reason to work here
we're very proud we stood up for our
employees we refused to comply day one
we sued we brought this to court we
spent our own money to do it we urge you
to subscribe and join us in the mission
because we are in fact we're an llc
which means we are a for-profit company
but we are a missional company
attempting to get things done okay so i
say that i was proud we stood up for our
employees and some guy named sam cedar
who's i guess a left-wing pundit he says
stood up for employees should be read as
quote defended the right of employers to
force its workers back to work without
even the protection of knowing that
those around them tested negative for a
deadly virus but here is the thing
number one
we never suggested that our workers
could not wear masks anybody who wants
to wear a mascara at the daily wire is
perfectly welcome to do so you can run
n95 as much as you damn well please you
can ignore everyone we don't care
what we said is that we are not going to
force people to take a vaccine against
their will in order to retain their job
but according to sam cedar this makes us
discriminatory and bad
according to the left
everything that is not compulsory is
forbidden
that's the way that this works
the government mandates because the
government is good
and anything that the government does
not mandate you are forbidden from doing
everything not compulsory is forbidden
this is the way the left thinks there is
only one great moral force in the
universe and it is government by the way
i love how
sam cedar suggests here
that what we are trying to do is
defending our right to force our workers
back to work without the protection of
knowing that those around them were he
doesn't know my employees he doesn't
know any of them i know all of them and
let me tell you something our employees
were crying in the office in nashville
yesterday because they literally thought
that they were on the verge of losing
their job at the best of joe biden
i know how many of my employees wanted
to get the facts i know how many of my
employees have natural immunity sam
cedar doesn't know the name of one of my
employees i could not tell you how tired
i am of hearing people on the left claim
that they care more about the people
whose salaries i pay and whose
livelihoods i insure than i do
i'm tired as hell of this nonsense it's
garbage
in the same way the left suggests that
they ought to control your children's
education you got terry mcauliffe out
there in virginia claiming you should
have no say in your child's education
you don't know the name of my child you
don't know a damn thing about my kid
i care much more about my kid than you
do you pretending that you're an expert
on how i should raise my kid is insane
and you pretending that you're an expert
on my relationship with my employees
who again their their bills are paid
because they work here and choose to
work here because it's a free country
you're out of your mind you're the great
defender of my employees
why i take a poll with my employees on
that
i mean really or you don't bother you
you just get to speak for them because
you are so wise you're the expert just
like the administrative agencies you
guys are the experts and the experts
should rule on behalf of all of us free
choice should just be flushed down the
toilet and you should rule mostly
because you're so empathetic you care so
much now you don't have to know any of
the people that you're ruling
you don't have to know what they feel
what they think you don't have to know
their health status you don't know how
you don't have to know what they would
choose because their choice is
irrelevant only your choice is relevant
because you are the experts
you are the people who know the most
and that's why even their choices on how
to vote for a legislature are completely
irrelevant that should not matter
the legislature should be completely
thrown out the legislature should not
matter anymore it should be a bunch of
unelected experts people like sam cedar
deciding for everyone how life is to be
led
it should be the people who have been
versed in environmental studies at ucla
deciding for everyone in the united
states who works a job whether or not
they need to get a vaccine whether or
not they have natural immunity
via osha a statute passed in 1970.
this is what the left truly thinks
and we were this close to that being the
reality in the united states this close
like herod's breath close and this is
why the fight matters
and by the way anybody who suggests that
the dissent in the osha case for example
is really about the law
yeah it isn't it isn't because they
would have just found some other excuse
for why an administrative agency could
do whatever it wants
here's the thing about the left they
don't care whether it's osha they don't
care whether it's fannie mae and freddie
mac
they don't care whether it's health and
human services or the department of
education they don't care whether it's
the secretary of labor or the secretary
of the interior they don't care all that
matters is that unelected bureaucrats
get to do the things they want because
for them it's all power all the time
it's just a power game
it's not about your personal freedom it
is not about your ability to vote it is
not about your ability to choose your
own life path none of that it is about
their control over you
why well because it's an emergency and
the experts know what's best they know
what sure they've blown it every step of
the way but they know what's best here
is the dissent from briar sotomayor and
kagan quote every day coveted 19 poses
grave dangers to the citizens of this
country and particularly to its workers
the disease has now has by now killed
almost 1 million americans and
hospitalized almost 4 million it spreads
by person-to-person contact and confined
indoor spaces so causes harm in nearly
all workplace environments and in those
environments more than any others
individuals have little control and
therefore little capacity to manage risk
really more than any others
why more than any others
it seems like you don't have the
capacity to manage control risk around
you in nearly any area of life
covet 19 is in short a menace in work
settings the proof is all around us
since the disease is onset most
americans have seen their workplaces
transformed well actually we've seen
most places in american life transform
not just the workplaces but says the
dissent
the administrative agency charged with
ensuring health and safety in workplaces
did what congress commanded it to do it
took action to address cover 19's
continuing threat in those spaces
et cetera et cetera et cetera and again
the basic idea is that osha has the
authority because we think osha should
have the authority my favorite part of
this opinion is where they say even if
we thought that they didn't have the
authority we should let them do it quote
even if the merits were a close question
the court would badly error by issuing
this stay that is because a court may
not issue a stay unless the balance of
harms and the public interests support
the action
here they do not the lives and health of
the nation's workers are at stake and
the majority deprives the government of
a measure it needs to keep them safe
right so in other words we don't care
about the constitutional provisions we
don't care about the legislature it's an
emergency we think the government should
have the power to do it so the
government has the power to do it period
end of story
it's amazing
they say this agency's standard is
informed by a half century of experience
and expertise in handling workplace
health and safety issues the standard
has the virtue of political
accountability because the osha is
responsible to the president and the
president is responsible to the american
people that's a that's an amazing
statement osha is suddenly accountable
to the american people by what metric
seriously by what metric we can't fire
any of those people all those people are
unelected and unfireable by the american
people
they're answerable to the president
so therefore that's a democratic
institution that's a new one that's
really a new one the administrative
agencies are now democratic answerable
institutions because the president is
elected hmm
how at the legislature they're elected
more frequently there's higher turnover
but the way that the left sees it no no
it's between the administrative agencies
and the court its members are elected by
and accountable to no one
it's amazing nowhere in the dissenting
opinion do they actually take stock of
the fact that congress is supposed to be
the deciding body here
they say who decides how much protection
and of what kind americans workers
american workers need from cover 19 an
agency with expertise acting as congress
and the president's authorized or a
court
well how about congress how about
congress
you know the elected body how about that
one
okay and here's the thing when i say
that this has nothing to do with the
osha mandate
that's because it has nothing to do with
the ocean mandate
and the reason that i say that is
because if you take a look at the the
same group of three justices voted in
favor of upholding
the eviction moratorium from the cdc
you remember the cdc put forth an
eviction moratorium under president
trump
that suggested that you were not allowed
to evict people from their houses for a
particular period of time during the
original wave
it was unconstitutional at the time by
the way
under trump it was unconstitutional
forget about who's president
administrative agencies were not given
this sort of insane power
to issue an eviction moratorium by the
way it was an insane policy to begin
with given the fact that we were blowing
money into people's pockets at the rate
of seven trillion dollars in 2020.
you had to pay all your other bills but
not your rent anyway the supreme court
had struck that down right they said you
can't but there were three justices who
were in favor of upholding that
saying the cdc could actually force all
evictions in the united states to stop
breyer and senator kagan wrote in that
case quote the cdc has issued an order
that in light of the rise of covet 19
delta variant temporarily prohibits
certain evictions in high transmission
counties through october 3rd today this
court without full briefing or argument
blocks that order
i think the court is wrong to do so and
i descend
they say that the cdc does not lack the
power to issue its modified moratorium
order
probably they have that power
they say that the statutes sentence
grants the cdc authority to design
measures that are in the agency's
judgment essential to contain disease
outbreaks
so again that is so crazy that you get
the cdc in order to prevent these
outbreaks gets to prevent all evictions
in the united states
all of them
okay but this is the whole point it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter they
don't like evictions therefore evictions
are bad and because evictions are bad
the government gets to do it and if
congress doesn't authorize
administrative agencies to do it that
doesn't matter either because those
administrative agencies are super giant
experts and the experts get to do
whatever they want so long as the
experts on the supreme court
greenlighted
that is the view of the left wing of
this court
and we were this close to that left wing
not being a minority but being a
majority on this court that's how close
we were
remember that's the battle because that
is the battle for the future in this
country the battle is going to be
whether there is any answer ability at
all at the federal level we held the
federal government accountable because
the supreme court was staffed by six
republican appointees
it is that simple
but there would be no way to hold the
federal government accountable for this
kind of tyranny if that court had ruled
the other way
keep that in mind because the battle for
the future is about that issue who gets
to decide you and your local government
your state government
or federal government officials who are
not even elected
you know how many layers of
unconstitutionality you have to you have
to breach in order to get to this idea
in the first place first you have to
assume that congress has the power to do
this congress does not have the power to
do this nowhere does congress have the
enumerated power under the constitution
of the united states to force hundreds
of millions of americans to vaccinate
that is not in the enumerated powers of
the constitution of the united states in
article one it is not then you have to
say okay well even if congress can't do
that maybe they can do it but congress
doesn't even have to pass a law saying
they can do it they can just say osha
can do whatever it wants
so then you have to assume that congress
is allowed to delegate enormous amounts
of power it does not possess to the
administrative agencies and then those
administrative agencies can use power
that they don't possess which they've
received from congress which doesn't
possess those powers to do whatever the
hell it wants
and yet this is exactly the way the left
in this country would love for this
country to run
when you talk about the corruption of
democracy and the destruction of
small-republicanism when you talk about
the destruction of the constitution and
the destruction of federalism
this is the true threat that's a real
authoritarian threat we fought it back
here at daily wire yesterday but that
battle is ongoing please join us at
dailywire.com subscribe and help us out
in fighting that battle in one second
we'll get to the other case that the
supreme court ruled on yesterday it went
the wrong way on this one this is with
regard to medical workers and and the
attachment of medicare and medicaid
dollars to vaccine mandates we'll get to
that in just one second first let us
talk about the most comfortable
underwear on planet earth i of course
i'm talking about tommy john underwear
they grace this magnificent rock like it
took us every single day when you start
the year wearing tommy john you are that
much more comfortable so you can do
everything better tommy john men's
underwear has breathable lightweight
moisture wicking fabric with four times
the stretch of competing brands you'll
feel the same level of comfort layering
their luxuriously soft lounge or right
on top tommy john loungewear is so
comfortable and good-looking you can and
will be wearing them everywhere with the
over 17 million pairs sold tommy john
does not have customers they have
fanatics again i wear tommy john stuff
my wife wears tommy john's stuff is just
they have all sorts of great gear and
arranges from underwear to loungewear
it's
all sorts of wonderful comfortable stuff
it's all backed by tommy john's best
pair you'll ever wear or it's free
guarantee get 20 off your first order
right now at tommyjohn.com
go to tommyjohn.com for 20 off
tommyjohn.com
see sight forward details this stuff is
so good i threw away all my other
underwear they're just that good i can
only wear tommy john now they've ruined
it for everything else tommyjohn.com for
off all right we'll get some more of the
news in just one second first as you
know yesterday the daily wire was a part
of history the supreme court blocked
that tyrannical biden administration
backs mandate for private employers we
were a major part of that we were the
first company in the united states to
file a federal lawsuit against the biden
administration i'm thrilled that the
risk that we took paid off and i'm
thrilled that you are a part of that if
you are a member you should become a
member today because these are the kinds
of fights that we fight right we fought
back this osha vax mandate we were part
of that loudoun county revolution in
terms of how we covered that we fight
here at the daily weather and we need
your help to do that we need your help
in order to fight back against the
authoritarian tyranny that the left
pushes each and every day please head on
over to dailywire.com
subscribe and today because we keep
winning promo code winning buys you an
annual subscription 40
off that's for today only 40 off because
we are into the winning here at
dailywear dailywear.com subscribe use
promo code winning because we're going
to keep on winning get 40 off your
annual subscription today be a part of
the conservative movement that fights
head on over to dailywire.com subscribe
again use promo code winning for 40 off
your subscription today also we have a
brand new thing that you get if you
become a member i mean this is just one
of my favorite things i'm really excited
about this i want to do this for a
couple of years
i've started a book club the first event
is now less than a week away it takes
place next thursday 8 p.m eastern 7 00
p.m central every month i recommend a
book it has earned an important spot in
western civilized culture a lot of these
books are not particularly well loved by
the left but they are indeed classics
it's all classics all the time not only
will we be reading a new book every
month you'll also get exclusive access
to my personal notes and analysis and
then on the third thursday of each month
i will join dailywire members online for
an in-depth lecture and discussion of
each book you can ask me questions
directly this month's book the first
book 1984 by george orwell so we're
reading that together this month that
hurry up because it's not too late to
sign up just head on over to third
thursdaybookclub.com to make a great
gift for high school and college
students as well head on over to third
thursdaybookclub.com receive the
materials you will need to participate
in our first members-only discussion on
january 20th i know a lot of you still
have that new year's resolution to read
more this year this helps you do it head
on over to third thursdaybookclub.com
get started on your reading goals today
grab a copy of 1984 by george orwell to
join us next thursday january 20th 8 p.m
eastern 7 pm central you are listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so there are actually two decisions that
came down yesterday from the supreme
court one was on the major employers vax
mandate the other was on the hospitals
around the country the supreme court
found five to four with kavanaugh and
roberts joining the left of the court of
course
shock that the medicare and medicare
programs could be attached to vax
mandates essentially they argued that
medicare and medicaid which were strings
attached programs right that one of the
strings they can attach is that
everybody has to be forced to get a
vaccine at medical facilities now this
is really stupid policy just as a matter
of policy it's really really stupid the
reason it's really stupid is because we
have massive medical shortages right now
across the country phil kerpin reported
yesterday we've lost 49 000 staffed
hospital beds in the last 365 days 16
000 in the last 30 and the biden
administration is celebrating the
supreme court letting them fire nurses
and doctors who have already had covet a
couple of times for declining a vaccine
that does not reduce omicron
transmission that is correct by the way
how bad is this
apparently california is now telling
coveted positive medical workers to stay
on the job so the way this works is if
you're not vaccinated
but you also don't have covid you can't
work at a hospital but
if you're vaccinated and have covid head
on into work today
according to yahoo news day long waits
in the emergency rooms no one to answer
the phones no one's to take out the
trash more patients arriving every day
that's the scene playing out at some
hospitals across southern california as
the omicron fueled surge of coven 19
contributes to a crippling shortage of
doctors doctors nurses and other
healthcare workers state officials are
attempting to address california's
staffing shortage through a sweeping
policy change that allows asymptomatic
healthcare workers who have tested
positive for covid to return to work
immediately
so yeah these vax mandates are they're
definitely great policies they make
perfect perfect sense and well the
supreme court basically found in
ridiculous fashion that the the enabling
act for medicare and medicaid somehow
can be cobbled together
to allow for the possibility of these
vast mandates being crammed down on
medical workers across the country as
the dissenters thomas alito gorsuch and
barrett point out
no not so much
they say the government has not
established that either provision of cms
which is the enabling act empowers it to
impose a vax mandate rules carrying out
the administration of medicare and
medicaid are those that serve the
practical management and direction of
those programs such rules are necessary
to administration if they bear an actual
discernible nexus to the program's
practical management
to the extent the rule has any
connection to the management of medicare
and medicaid it is the most hand
tangential one at oral argument the
government largely conceded that these
statutes alone do not authorize the
omnibus rule instead it fell back on a
constellation of statutory provisions
that each concern one of the 15 types of
medical facilities the rule covers
several of those provisions contain
language indicating that cms may
regulate those facilities in the
interest of health and safety in the
government's view that language
authorizes cms to adopt any requirements
that cms deems necessary including a vax
mandate
the government has not made a strong
showing that this agglomeration of
statutes authorizes any such rule to
start five of those 15 facility specific
statutes don't authorize cms to impose
health and safety regulations at
all these provisions can't support an
argument based on statutory texts they
lack perhaps that's why the government
only weakly defends them then the
government identifies eight definitional
provisions describing for example what
makes a hospital a hospital
these define covered facilities as those
that comply with a variety of conditions
etc
the government similarly invokes a
saving clause for health and safety
regulations applicable to all inclusive
care programs for the elderly
the government has not made a strong
showing this hodgepodge of provisions
authorizes a nationwide vax mandate we
presume congress does not hide
fundamental details of a regulatory
scheme in vague or ancillary provisions
yet here the government proposes to find
virtually unlimited vaccination power
over millions of healthcare workers in
definitional provisions a saving clause
and a provision regarding long-term care
facilities sanitation procedures
yeah i mean it's a stretch it is for
sure a giant stretch for his part ronda
sanchez in florida he says we're not
going to help you implement this and in
fact hospitals in florida are now caught
between a bit of a rock and a hard place
because in florida you are not allowed
to discriminate against the unvaccinated
that is state law in the state of
florida you can't fire somebody for
being unvaccinated at the same time the
federal government has now mandated that
they are going to remove medicare and
medicaid dollars from hospitals if they
don't force their employees to get vast
here's ron desantis yesterday in florida
the medical mandate for the for the
nurses and the doctors this is what
they're trying to do is absolutely
insane in other states they have fired
nurses
for not having vacs even though most of
them have natural immunity so they fire
them but now they're short-handed so
what are they doing they are bringing
back on the job
vaccinated nurses who are co currently
covered positive so if you're
unvaccinated naturally immune and
uninfected your they fire you
but if you're covered positive and vax
which we know most of the people that
are covered positive now are backs
they are going back on the job and it
just shows you that cms mandate is
absolutely insane especially given the
ineffectiveness you know of of these
shots to actually stop transmission
random stances of course is exactly
correct and shame on kavanaugh and
roberts were voting the wrong way on
this particular mandate okay meanwhile
joe biden's presidency is in a state of
full-scale collapse it really is i mean
this is the worst week i have ever seen
a president have maybe it is definitely
up there aside from the baturi in
afghanistan which was a weeks-long
rolling crisis for the administration it
destroyed biden's credibility this week
has been brutal so joe biden this week
alone received reports of inflation at a
40-year high
joe biden had his vast mandate struck
down by the supreme court
joe biden is running up against a major
border crisis again again
joe biden's approval rating is down at
33 according to quinnipiac
joe biden has decided to swivel away
from all of those things by randomly
shouting about how all americans who
dislike his voting agenda are vicious
racists
and now that's breaking down even his
own parties like you're acting like a
jackass please stop okay so yesterday
joe biden went to the hill he's been
trying to convince senators on the hill
that they ought to get rid of the
filibuster yeah good luck with that joe
manchin and christian cinema have no
interest in getting rid of the
filibuster there's no reason they would
be interested in getting rid of the
filibuster why the filibuster protects
them and protects probably half a dozen
other democratic senators because those
democratic senators now get to claim
that they're in favor of a bunch of
democratic legislative proposals
without those proposals ever having to
be passed
and that's a pretty good space to be in
the filibuster allows mansion and cinema
to hide behind the filibuster in order
to not have to vote on very
controversial proposals in their own
home state plus it turns out that the
filibuster has long time been a feature
of the senate it is a good cooling
mechanism for the excesses of
congressional passion
okay so joe biden went on down to the
hill yesterday
and
it just it went it went horribly just
horribly it started off before he even
went down
with jen saki at the white house saying
joe biden thinks that we need to make
changes to the filibuster and it's super
duper important
any piece of legislation that's ever
passed uh that's hard that's difficult
goes through it goes through some ups
and downs and goes through some
challenges that doesn't mean you give up
that's not what leadership is leadership
is continuing to fight for what's right
continuing to fight to get something
done uh that means sometimes it fails we
don't know what will happen next that
means sometimes uh there or are gaps
between when you get to move forward
we're going to have to determine what
the next steps are but in the meantime
the president is going to continue to
make calls he's going to continue to
engage with his colleagues uh and that's
where his focus is on at this point in
time yeah well he has no power to do
that because the president of the united
states is not a sentient being he's an
old man who shouts at the clouds and
calls everybody who doesn't like his
agenda a vicious bull conor racist even
though it was he who was serving in the
senate with people like george wallace
and praising them at the time okay so
here was joe biden he goes down to the
hill and randomly he starts yelling
about voting this is not going to get
the job done sir
the state legislative bodies continue to
change the law not as to who can vote
but who gets to count the vote
count the vote
it's about election subversion
not just whether or not people get to
vote
who counts the vote
that's what this about that's what makes
this so different than anything else
we've ever done who counts the vote who
counts the vote count to vote counsel
vote counts the
not gonna work dude not gonna work in
fact this works so poorly that yesterday
kirsten cinema well he was in this
i mean she just burned him to the ground
so joe biden goes to the senate to try
and convince kirsten cinema and joe
manchin that they should give up on
their own political prospects so that
this old man can pass a voting bill
that
she doesn't even like okay and and so
she gets up on the senate floor and
she's like you know what i'm not doing
that i'm not doing that and you can
shove off sir
while i continue to support these bills
i will not support separate actions that
worsen the underlying disease of
division infecting our country
the debate over the senate 60 vote
threshold shines a light on our broader
challenges
there's no need for me to restate my
long-standing support for the 60-vote
threshold to pass legislation
there's no need for me to restate its
role protecting our country from wild
reversals and federal policy so that is
kirsten cinema just taking joe biden
breaking her back like bane with batman
and dark knight rises i mean it's just
that is a um
that is a bad sight for joe biden and by
the way joe biden knows it he went to
these meetings and then as he was
leaving he got very very agitated
because his medication had run out
i hope we can get this done the honest
to god answer is i don't know whether we
can get this done as long as i have a
breath in me
as long as i'm in the white house as
long as i'm engaged at all i'm going to
be fighting to change the way these
legislatures have moving
as long as i it's pretty dark sir as
long as i brought over my call
joe manchin then put out a statement in
solidarity with cinema
just add insult to injury for the
administration quote
throughout the last decade or more
there's been broad bipartisan support
for protecting the filibuster including
current and former members of the senate
just four years ago 61 senators 33 of
whom were democrats sent a letter to
senators chuck schumer and mitch
mcconnell warning them of the dangers of
eliminating the filibuster that letter
presented a united front committed to
preserve the ability of members to
engage in extended debate when bills are
on the floor while some of them have
changed their position i have not
respect is a two-way street i respect
that they have changed i would hope they
would respect that i have not while many
try to ignore this history they do so
without fully understanding the
long-term institutional and democratic
damage this will do to the senate and
our nation allowing one party to exert
complete control in the senate with only
a simple majority we'll only pour fuel
onto the fire of political whiplash and
dysfunction that is tearing this nation
apart this is joe manchin's statement
he says for those who believe
bipartisanship is impossible we proved
them wrong ending the filibuster would
be the easy way out i can't support such
a perilous course for this nation when
elected leaders are sent to washington
to unite our country by putting politics
and party aside so joe biden reduced to
a sniveling whining shell of a sniveling
whining man so that's that's it's been a
very very very
bad week for joe biden by the way the
democrats are still relying on the
filibuster
and so you think that because they're in
control of the senate they don't use the
filibuster wrong so yesterday there was
a majority bill there's a support for a
bill 55 members of the senate supported
it
they would have blocked sanctions that
would have reimposed sanctions on
companies that did business with the
russian pipeline nordstrom 2.
that legislation was called the
protecting europe's energy security
implementation act it received a floor
vote after republican texas senator ted
cruz who had proposed it agreed to
release several administration
nominations he had blocked over the
issue
and um then the senate democrats blocked
it
using wait for it wait for it wait for
the filibuster
so while they are declaring it a racist
hallmark of jim crow they're literally
using the filibuster to save joe biden's
pro nordstrom 2 position
absolutely incredible
and this presidency is a mess this party
is a mess and so joe biden has been
reduced to just
saying random things and hoping
something sticks so yesterday he did an
address in which he talked about oh
macron and
again he's got no power he's got no
ability to do anything at this point
he's a lame duck one year into his
presidency it's really amazing and so
now he's just going to let all of his
authoritarian id run free he says you
know what i would love i would love for
social media and for the media to stop
their misinformation nothing like the
president of the united states
attempting to use the power of the
federal government to cuddle the media
into place that's good i thought this is
a threat to journalism when trump did it
when biden does it it's good
if you haven't gotten vaccinated do it
personal choice impacts us all
our hospitals our countries
i make a special appeal to social media
companies and media outlets please deal
with the misinformation and
disinformation that's on your shows it
has to stop please also he he also he
says wearing a mask is a patriotic duty
um he doesn't specify which kind of mask
here he is
as i've said in the last two years
please wear a mask
if you're in a you know i i think it's
part of your patriotic duty it's not
that comfortable
it's a pain in the neck
but
i've taken every action i can as
president to require people to wear
masks in federal buildings and on
airplanes and trains because they're
internet they cross state lines and and
it's been so wildly effective sir i mean
i mean it's not like we have any omicron
cases at all because because of those
measures
really great job i mean in new jersey
new york you know places where everybody
agrees with you
i've noticed that um everyone's getting
infected with donald cron
by the way even michael osterholm who
used to advise biden he's like this is
an amazing statement so he says cloth
masks don't work against omicron but
then he goes further he says the thing
you are not allowed to say the kind of
thing that gets you banned from youtube
if you are a member of the non-liberal
party if you're not a leftist and you
say this
then you're treated like joe rogan
you're an abomination unto the lord
here's michael osterholm saying
something about cloth masks that has
been perfectly obvious for nyan two
years but you weren't supposed to say it
here he is
the science was there we published uh
work back as early as april of 2020
saying that in fact that this virus is
transmitted by an aerosol that kind of
perfume like floating in the room and
that we needed to have that very high
level of respiratory protection you need
these very tight face fitting masks that
also have breathable and what i mean by
that is it's fit and its filtration and
the way you get fit is like a swim
goggle you can't have it leak but if
it's going to be that tight then you
have to have a material that allows the
air to move through cloth doesn't do
that
wait what now
hold up so he just said one second you
need a tight fit
which would be can 95 or 95. you need
that
but anything that's loosely fit
or of a or of a material like cloth
doesn't work and he says we had data of
this in
april of 2020. if you said this for a
year and a half on the internet you were
banned
you're banned they would throw you off
facebook for this they would throw you
off youtube for this michael osterholm
can say it he was an advisor to joe
biden he's liars he's unbelievable liars
okay so it's all falling apart for them
the good news is they have waiting in
the wings one of the most talented
politicians of this or any other
generation kamala harris who is just
she's just an inspiring figure deeply
inspiring figure so kamala harris did an
interview
on nbc news it's one of the great
interviews of all time
uh kamala harris is perennially the
third grader whose dog ate her homework
forever and always
she has two responses to questions to
laugh hysterically like a lunatic
or to try and soldier her way through
them like michael scott being asked to
describe the french revolution here is
here is kamala harris being asked a very
simple question and man this answer this
is an all-time great answer right here
six former
administration officials last week wrote
that open letter urging the
administration to change course to
change strategy
is it time
it is time for us to
do what we have been doing and that time
is every day
every day it is time for us to agree
that
there are things and tools that are
available to us to slow this thing down
she she's the most talented politician
of our generation
and by the way every two days there's a
piece in the mainstream media about why
she needs to recapitulate her image
there's another one in the washington po
like it's almost every two days like why
her comms team is failing her because
the dictator can never fail the decision
can only be failed maybe she just sucks
at this that's one of the great
selena kyle v blinds i have ever heard
from a politician in real life quote it
is time there's a direct quote it is
time for us to do what we have been
doing and that time
is every day
okay i'm trying to get a handle on what
that means
today right now it's the time for us to
do what we've already been doing and
that time
to do what we've already been doing is
every day and so the past and present
and future all merge
it's like a it's like a flat circle
yeah play it again play i need that i
need the experience of that level of
genius again i need it i need it i
require it this could be your next
president of the united states folks
because joe biden needed a black woman
for veep
six former
administration officials last week wrote
that open letter urging the
administration to change course to
change strategy
is it time
it is time for us to
do what we have been doing and that time
is every day
every day it is time everything is time
to agree to a that
there are things and tools that are
available to us to slow this thing down
my favorite time is that it is time for
us to do what we have been doing and
that time of is every day
every day
is that time
it's like a haiku
for a person who has no brain function
it's that is that is
fantastic that is just fantastic
i guess that the the goal here is that
our leadership class should be actively
unable to form english sentences about
coherent policy
we're almost there guys if we just work
a little harder we'll get there alrighty
we have reached the end of today's show
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content first you
cannot forget to end your week by tuning
in to the andrew clavin show drew's
shows every friday he's got an exciting
evening planned for you so head on over
to dailywire.com 7pm eastern 6 p.m
central tune in i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo wydowski associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
high event audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
christina production assistant jessica
crand the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood but on the andrew clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
clavin show and laugh your way through
the fall of the republic with me andrew
clavin